cette association répond au besoin dans
l'urgence à l'accepter patients que la
société refuse ou qui semblent
impossibles à améliorer
[Musique]
je le recommande vraiment on va aller
voir ce film c'est vraiment un super
film est à tout point de vue vraiment
très très émouvant tous les cas c'est
tout chaud c'est éprouvant et en même
temps on s'est mis ces merveilleuses
qu'il faut vraiment très juste
avec un jeu d'acteur fantastique et puis
non à une certaine réalité qui est qui
qui nous laisse je me laisse pantoise
qui ça arrive à les sortir un petit peu
quand même du néant
salut petit ou petit jeu confiante tu es
bien un garçon c'est pas tout tu viens
il s'échappe et je veux récupérer
bayetti j'ai adoré c'était trop cool
j'ai bien aimé film parce qu il est il a
bien été réalisée c'est très bien et il
faut protéger les animaux c'est pour les
enfants c'est un bon moment il ya des
musiques sympa c'est joli c'est une
histoire qui se laisse regarder
c'est plutôt familiale tout le monde
peut y aller les petits les grands les
moyens pour tout le monde
[Musique]